if i didn't have that i would be dead  right now [ __ ] i might start crying  talking about it but um i've always my  entire life  have valued friends over everything  right i would do  anything for my friends because you hear  stories you're like oh yeah we used to  be friends in college and you know life  happens and then we grow and i was like  no  like things come and go the one thing  that has to like stay constant in my  life is friendship so i nurtured those  things i made sure no matter what  happened in my life i would take trips i  would call if i didn't have that i would  be dead right now i can tell you three  stories right now where if i didn't have  a guy in my life that was like we're not  doing this dave like i would i would be  dead right now one of the most important  things for for my life and my recovery  is these friendships are invaluable